Alright now, let's talk about the professional way to end this conversation.
Just like the beginning of the conversation might have seemed a little bit formal to you,...
...the ending might seem a little formal to you, as well.
What you traditionally want to do,...
...is give a brief wrap-up or summary or reiteration of what the solution...
...or what was the outcome of the phone conversation.
OK so, we're going to change part A,...
...we're gonna leave part B,...
...and we're going to cut out part C.
Whatever happened in that conversation,...
...you don't have to repeat the whole conversation,...
...but just restate it in a sentence or two.
It is always proper business etiquette, at the end of a phone conversation,...
...to say something like, "Thank you, I'll see you Friday."
"Thank you for your time."
"Thank you for your business."
Alright? "Thank you" for something.
It doesn't have to be just a random "thank you",...
...but it could be a random "thank you",...
...or it could be a "thank you", specific to something.
And then, you just simply say, "Goodbye."
You know, you wanna avoid some of the more contemporary slang terms for goodbye like "Later dude."
Okay? You wanna stay away from that.
Just simply, "Thank you for your time. Goodbye."
"Thank you for your time and I'll see you Friday."
"Thank you, I'll see you Friday."
"Thank you, Bob. Goodbye."
Alright? Leave it at that.
That is professional.